[Music]
welcome to another episode of code this
not that where we try to write the best
code possible and avoid the bad stuff
today we'll look at loops or iteration
and JavaScript which is a lot more
interesting than you might think we'll
look at this from both a readability and
performance perspective to figure out
the best loop to write in your code if
you're new here like and subscribe and I
recommend following along with the
source code on fire ship IO and if you
want to see more videos like this one
let me know in the comments when we talk
about loops we're actually talking about
iteration which happens when we tell a
computer to do something over and over
again until we tell it to stop the best
way to understand this is by looking at
the traditional for loop first we need
to keep track of the number of
iterations that we've made which usually
starts at zero then we need a condition
to stop the loop and then we need to
increment the counter each time an
iteration is completed it's kind of like
saying start here stop here and do this
after each completed loop this loop is
very explicit because we can look at it
and understand exactly what it's doing
without making any assumptions but this
code is kind of hard to digest and
usually as programmers we want to write
as little code as possible and make that
code understandable to other human
beings
luckily javascript provides two other
ways to loop over things that are much
more sugary and easier to understand for
the average person the first one is the
for of loop and it's very similar to a
for loop except we use the of keyword
and pass and the thing that we're
iterating over certain things in
JavaScript are iterable for example
arrays maps and strings so in this case
javascript will assume that we're
iterating to the end of this array and
will give us access to the elements in
the array inside of the brackets so when
just looping over an array this is a lot
less mental overhead than a traditional
for loop but in order to really
understand what's going on here let's
look at things at a lower level the
array itself is iterable and it
implements an iterator function that
allows it to be looped over we can
actually override the default behavior
of the for of loop by implementing our
own iterator function so when we use the
object in a for loop it's going to call
this iterator function over and over
again so what that means is we need to
implement the same logic that we had in
that traditional for loop so first we
set up an index at 0 then the array
itself will be that this context inside
of this function
now the actual spec itself requires us
to return an object that has a next
property which is itself a function that
returns an object that will tell the
loop whether or not it's done and also
provide the current value at this
iteration so this isn't something that
you would have to deal with on a daily
basis but it's good to know that
JavaScript provides a way for you to
make your own classes iterable or
override the default iteration behavior
on an existing object so I like to put
emojis everywhere so I'm gonna go ahead
and add an emoji to every item in the
loop so obviously it's not a very
practical use case but you can see we're
just doing a regular for of loop here
but we're getting additional emojis
added to the items in the loop well look
at some more tricks we can do with four
of in just a minute but there's also one
other way we can loop over items and
that's using a for each loop in this
case we're calling a method that exists
on JavaScript arrays and we'll look at a
bunch of these a little bit later but
basically it just allows us to pass a
callback function that will be executed
for every item in that array so we could
go ahead and console.log the value or we
could even simplify this because
console.log itself is a function and we
can just pass it in like this so it
gives you the opportunity to write
really concise functional code but when
I did my original code this not that
video a few months ago that main
criticism was not considering the
performance implications of these
different types of loops those are
absolutely valid points so let's go
ahead and look at the performance side
by side I've created an array with a
million items in it and we'll go ahead
and run our loops inside of a console
timer first up is the traditional for
loop and you want to try to optimize
your loop to do as little work in the
loop itself as possible for example you
don't want to call array dot length if
you don't have to so in this case we'll
start by calling array dot length in the
loop and we get about 1.7 milliseconds
if we just go ahead and pass in the
number directly we get slightly better
performance at about 1.6 milliseconds
next up is the for of loop and when we
run this you can see we get about 11 to
12 milliseconds that's about 6 times
longer which is pretty crazy but when
you think about all the extra work in
that iterator function that we
implemented earlier then that
performance loss makes sense but that
shouldn't scare you away from using 4 of
because if you're only looping over say
a thousand things it's not going to
matter it's really only a concern when
every nanosecond counts and at that
point you might want to consider
something other than
javascript now back in our tests will
try for each and we'll see that we get
much better performance than for of at
around two milliseconds or so but the
interesting thing about these methods is
that they can be chained together and
each one that you've chained together is
a another iteration over the entire
array so this time we'll add nap before
we do our for each loop and now you can
see our performances around 10
milliseconds so that's roughly 2
milliseconds from the for each loop and
then another 8 seconds for map we can
add another map in there and the
performance will continue to decrease
this time around 18 to 20 milliseconds
so again this probably won't matter if
you have a small array but something to
keep in mind if performance is critical
now for the rest of the video we're
going to switch gears and just write
some code that solves common problems
that you'll encounter when running a
loop the first one is how do you loop
over an object because an object is not
iterable by default although you could
technically implement your own symbol
iterator like we did earlier the easiest
method is to just change your for of
loop to a for in loop that will loop
over all of the keys in the object then
you can simply use that key to access
the value from the original object
itself another alternative would be to
keep the for of loop in its original
form but this time use object values on
the original object that will convert
all of the values to an array which of
course is iterable and if you have an
object that you know you need to loop
over in different ways I recommend
converting it to a map a map shares a
lot of similarities with a regular
object except it maintains the order of
the keys in which they were inserted in
other words if you want to maintain a
specific order of the key value pairs in
the object then you definitely want to
use a map and not a plain JavaScript
object we can convert it by a calling
object entries on the original object
inside of the map constructor and we can
loop over it by simply calling the
values method on the map itself now
let's take a look at some of the very
awesome methods that are available on
the modern JavaScript array so here we
have an array of faces but you might
notice one that doesn't quite fit it was
meant to go in a completely different
array so let's go ahead and create that
array by filtering it out of the
original we can do that by calling
filter on the original array and keep in
mind this is not removing it from the
original array but instead creating a
new array with only that value so we can
do this all in one line with array
filter instead of setting up a for loop
which would at least take
five lines of code filter is pretty
useful but I think the most useful
method is map it allows you to take the
incoming elements in the array and
transform them into something else
but a lot of times when you're looping
over an array you're just testing that
it contains something or maybe it
doesn't contain something in our case
we're going to iterate over our faces
array to see if it contains a certain
unwanted emoji if any of the elements
return true on this function then the
sum method on the array will return true
and on a similar note we can use the
every method to ensure that every
element in the array follows some
pattern in our case we're just making
sure that it's a high Unicode character
which is where the emojis live now let's
say we had some more unwanted characters
in this array and we want to see how bad
the situation is by counting all of the
unwanted characters the array reduce
method allows us to loop over the array
while accumulating a certain value and
by accumulate I just mean a value that
changes after each iteration of the loop
so the callback value contains that
accumulated value as the first argument
and then the current value in the loop
as the second argument so all we're
going to do is test that the emoji is
the unwanted character and if so we'll
add one otherwise we'll add zero and
when using reduce you have the option to
pass the second argument which is the
starting value to accumulate from which
in our case would just be zero so now we
know that we have three unwanted
characters in this array so let's go
ahead and sort it so all of the unwanted
characters are at the end we have a
another array method just for that
called a race sort it allows you to pass
in a compare function to sort the array
based on whatever logic you want once we
have that sort of the way we want it we
can then call splice on the array to get
rid of the elements that we don't need
I'm going to go ahead and wrap things up
there hopefully this video showed you
that there is always more than one way
to solve a problem in JavaScript make
sure to grab the full source code from
fire ship IO thanks for watching and I
will talk to you soon
[Music]